where there was chaos and much confusion
now there's action for the authorities
and the aid agencies know what they're
dealing with cyclone edye has displaced
230,000 and many more lack food and
clean water but help has arrived
and much of it is from Britain the UK is
one of the biggest contributors to this
response but getting supplies to the
people who need it is tricky
some people want tents and pots and pans
others need water purification kits it's
a major logistical exercise clean water
is key with cholera now threatening
Mozambique so diffidence Development
Agency has provided filters and other
supplies but they have to get it to the
people who need it and the world food
programs helicopter will help
it's drying says Pedro Matos the
national coordinator a couple of days
ago it looked like this but the waters
receding and the pilots can land in
areas that were previously off-limits
places like gunda a human chain was
assembled to unload the cargo and a
large crowd assembled to watch many seem
relieved we're all suffering said this
man but there are thousands of people
who live outside this town residents of
communities that were cut off for days
there's Park that we know and that we're
doing operation but we're keeping a
little bit of flexibility from yesterday
we reached a place 18 kilometers from
here so we didn't know about when we
heard from this farmer about this
isolated community so we redirect Lee
one of the helicopters
this disaster demanded an international
response with resources the Mozambicans
cannot provide the country's
ex-president has expressed his things
are they providing enough help at the
moment Mozambique yes I very much
grateful for what I saw as a response
from the international community because
the knowledge of what is happening when
there are calamities like this comes a
bit late and even the government does
not know how to make an appeal because
the government may not know what is
happening because there is no
communication and so on mr. Sano what's
the UK to stick around and the British
public have answered his call raising
millions of pounds in donations so
Mozambique can rebuild John sparks Sky
News Berra